I'm going to play for you
um some number of incoherent seconds I
guess it's about 90 seconds of my pillow
founder and CEO Mike Lindell appearing
on Steve bannon's program and I have to
tell you at this point I genuinely don't
know whether Steve Bannon takes Lindell
seriously because Bannon is as much of
an incoherent joke as Lindell or whether
Bannon sees Lindell more of his like as
a as a goofy entertainment element but
he doesn't take him seriously there was
a segment on Steve bannon's actually I'm
wrong this was on Lindell TV
you know what I don't know where this
seems to have been a simulcast both on
Lindell TV and on on Steve bannon's war
room I don't know where pillow is upset
with Ron DeSantis for some reason he's
calling him a backstabber and all these
different things the segment starts with
Mike pillow literally holding a pillow
and then moving it out of frame I wasn't
able to find what took place in the 15
seconds before this clip starts but the
presence of the pillow makes me think it
might be pretty damn interesting
see if you can make heads or tails out
of this and then again if you're
listening imagine that as this segment
starts Mike pillow is moving a physical
pillow out of screen so what is going on
does Santa's a pretty straight guy what
is he heckling you because he's upset
about what you're doing in Miami-Dade or
what is a shot across Mike lindell's bow
what's going on here
well let me let me uh let me try and
frame this and this could we'll just say
uh we don't know why but uh you can draw
your own conclusion so this morning what
he hosted a lawyer uh six lawyers or so
in this uh uh in this little round table
well one of them is Libby lock who
represents Dominion voting machines
against it says rather thing against
Mike Lindell Rudy Giuliani and many
others you guys understanding this so
far and he called her in his opening
statement when he introduced her Libby
is an extraordinaire at First Amendment
defamation law
well I'm telling you Ron you didn't
watch that
you probably don't understand what's
going on in our country there's a reason
that the whole country wanted me to
beach head of the RNC well that
obviously isn't the case when they did
the raspa support it's because I want to
get rid of the machines and and make our
elections we're doing a class action
lawsuit against all machines elections
and not selections so what he did I told
the I told the Daily Beast today Steve
they called me and I said because they
watched it and I said let me tell you
something they called me and they said
sir I said he just blew any chance if he
was thinking of running for president
your ship is sale run you just throw
endorse Donald Trump right now and try
and save peace because you don't know
what the people want now I want to
remind everybody
that
um the D I believe it was the day after
Trump announced in November that he was
running in 2024
I don't remember what the context was
but the day after or two days later Mike
pillow said
DeSantis is about to endorse Trump
DeSantis isn't going to run in 24 any
day now he's going to come out and say
actually I endorsed Donald Trump now of
course that didn't happen like almost
all of Mike pillow's predictions it has
not come true but what is our
understanding of pillow at this point is
he deeply delusional or does he believe
the things he said I don't know the
answer I've interviewed pillow twice
I've most recently been leaning towards
he's serious about this stuff he means
it but now I'm sort of going back like
could anyone really be this delusional
does Steve Bannon take him seriously I
also don't nor know the answer to that I
I don't know what is going on with this
guy we can only hope and pray
that at least within the Republican
party uh which is the only place he has
any credibility left he is increasingly
seen as a joke and ostracized and moved
to the margins of the political
discussion but I knew that day that he
appeared at the White House during covet
with Trump to announce that he believes
Trump was uh god-given a god-given
president
gosh darn it
um you could tell this guy was trouble
and he certainly has turned out to be
trouble and he told me a few months ago
that he's like in for 35 million at that
point he was in for 35 million so far in
all of this election stuff and machines
and investigations and whatever
um it's got to be more than that by now
at some point the money's got to run out
you would think but uh there is the
latest from Mike pillow holding a pillow
for part of a segment with Steve Bannon